So we don't need immigration of skilled workers
or the labor market because of it?
In your opinion,
no,
immigration From foreign civilizations
creates more problems,
than we found positive results in the labor market.
um factors can bring.
Immigration From relatives,
so for example from poland,
is problem free,
for example From the Czech Republic is problem-free,
for example From Austria is problem-free,
From Italy is problem free.
It starts
in a slightly more eastern area,
for example,
immigration From anatolia is not quite problem-free.
Immigration From Afghanistan
brings with it significant problems.
Immigration - From Kazakhstan brings problems,
are other civilizations,
not because of their other genes,
not because of their other lineage,
but because of the way they are as an infant,
like her as a toddler,
like her as a schoolchild,
how they were raised as a child in the family.